if you've seen the batman did you wonder
where else you'd seen the actor who
played carmine falcone keep watching for
some of the many recognizable roles john
turturro has played deterro caught
director spike lee zai with his
performance in 1987's five corners so
lee cast him in his 1989 film do the
right thing in an interview with vanity
fair totoro said lee sent in the script
and asked which part he wanted to play
tutorial answered i said i'd like to
play the racist guy because i thought
that's what it was about setting it
predominantly black neighborhood in
brooklyn do the right thing explores
racial tensions between an
italian-american family running a
pizzeria and their neighbors lee himself
plays pizza delivery guy mookie and
totoro plays pino the racist son of the
pizzeria's owner in their key scene
together pino names his favorite
celebrities who are all black but then
says i mean they're not black i mean
let me explain myself
they're not really black and
i mean they're black but they're not
really black lee broke down the scene to
entertainment weekly pointing out that
line is key pino when he's talking it's
not based upon fiction i've heard this
argument for the most racist people
their favorite athlete entertainer or
comedian is black lee admitted he was
intimidated doing that scene calling to
turo a beast do the right thing kicked
off a long collaboration with totoro
appearing in several more of spike lee's
movies including jungle fever clockers
and mo better blues
john turturro is only in the big
lebowski for a few minutes but he made a
big impression as bowling competitor the
jesus dress in a purple jumpsuit jesus
quintana does an elaborate ritual before
he throws his ball down the lane after
getting a strike he does a dance insults
jeff bridges the dude and leaves it's a
fever dream in slow motion the eccentric
character was a collaboration between
totoro and joel and ethan cohen the
brothers who wrote directed and produced
the movie in an interview with vanity
fair totoro said that jesus is inspired
by a character he portrayed in a play a
decade earlier he asked for the painted
pinky nail and brought the hairnet
taturo said when you only have five
minutes you've gotta put everything in i
just kept trying to come up with things
to make the coen brothers laugh doturo
said the scene shocked even him he said
i didn't think they were going to use
all of that and then when they showed me
the cut of it i was embarrassed i was
laughing but i was embarrassed i was
like oh god i can't believe i did all
those things that embarrassment didn't
hold him back from bringing jesus back
for a sequel movie the jesus roles which
he wrote directed and starred in
tutorial explained everything he does is
a masterpiece in his own mind despite
the fact that everything he does
backfires
continuing his work with the coen
brothers john turturro starred in 2000's
oh brother guerrato alongside george
clooney and tim blake nelson the three
of them play escaped convicts in
depression era mississippi who embark on
an episodic journey to get back home the
film is loosely based on homer's the
odyssey with clooney's ulysses everett
mcgill taking the role of odysseus deter
rose pete and nelson's delmar are
dimwitted compared to ulysses cunning
but they follow him in hopes of finding
hidden treasure a brother where art
though is particularly known for its
iconic soundtrack of old folk songs
which became part of the story as a
group finds radio fame as a soggy bottom
voice totoro said of working with the
cohen's it's always a new world that
they create and it's fun to fill that
imaginary world out it's never the same
he also appeared in their movie miller's
crossing as the bookie bernie bernborn
and as the title playwright in the
cohen's film barton fink
look at your heart
i'm freaking you
[Music]
look in your heart
i'm praying to you
john tuturo hasn't done a lot of tv
until recently which is why his guest
appearance on monk was both special and
unusual mr monk himself tony shalhoub
asked atturo to come on the show since
the two of them are good friends and had
worked together before on barton fink
and the play waiting for godot turtaro
comes into the story in the season 2
episode mr monk and the three pies
playing adrian monk's brother ambrose
like adrian who's known for his
obsessive compulsive disorder and long
list of phobias ambrose monk has his own
collection of fears and quirks he hasn't
left their childhood house in over 30
years because of his severe agoraphobia
that's not the reason the two of them
are estranged though they haven't talked
in years because ambrose blames himself
for the death of adrian's wife but when
ambrose thinks his neighbor killed
someone he calls adrian to solve it and
the two awkwardly reunite it's a
favorite episode of shaloobs as a
strange relationship between the two
brothers reveals another side to his
character shaloub told usa today he's
more abrupt and less sympathetic it's a
healthy thing to see that he's not a
complete saint taturo won an emmy for
outstanding guest actor in a comedy
series and ended up coming back for two
more episodes season four's mr monk goes
home again and season 7's mr monk's
100th case before tuturo's second
episode aired shalub praised him to the
new york times somehow in two episodes
he's managed to take the character and
make him a fully rounded complete part
of the show
in four transformers movies tatura plays
the antagonist and ally agent seymour
simmons of the government's secretive
sector seven at the montclair film
festival taturo said he based his
performance on the movie's director
michael bay as he's done with other
directors and executive producers this
role was a big departure from turturro's
usual independent movies but he took the
job because of his son he told the
independent i never did any of those
kinds of movies till my kids asked me to
then they kept asking me to do it i
didn't do it for the paycheck i had fun
tried to get into the spirit of it it's
more of a sketch of a person than an oil
painting he says he prefers medium-sized
films for the big budget ones although
he said those roles have become harder
to find he told variety now there are no
medium-sized films there are small films
or giant films thank god for television
now sir toro is back with one of the
biggest films in recent memory the
batman
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one